next questions about interviews and
firstly what are they like
interviews are much feared and often
misunderstood things the purpose of an
interview is to recreate the conditions
of a tutorial or a supervision in
Cambridge to see how a candidate
performs and they formed such an
important part of the selection process
because much of the teaching done at
universities is done under the same
conditions and tutors want to choose
students who will get the most out of
that system as such interviews take the
form of a ten to thirty minute
discussion with academic about your
subject and some tutorials are done by
one academic some MOTU and others still
by panels of academics and other
officials both the universities realize
that candidates are scared of interviews
and so you are made to feel as
comfortable as you can be under the
circumstances it's also worth stating
that the tutors are not there to take
you apart to be aggressive they want to
see you do well as one of my tutor said
to me once the purpose of an interview
isn't to find out what you don't know
that would be way too easy
what it is is to find out what you do
know to find out how you think they are
trying to coax out of you how you
approach and solve problems and they
want to see you do well
they are looking for knowledge of your
subject but they're also looking for
problem solving an independent thought
form or official information about
interviews you can check out this link
for Oxford and this link for Cambridge
secondly do I need to submit work for my
interviews some subjects will require
you to do an aptitude test typically in
October or November before the interview
season in December while other subjects
will require you to submit written work
for your interviews needless to say this
vary substantially from subject to
subject and so check out the department
page for your subject for more
information about this note that some
subjects weren't required to do either
and so you won't have to do an aptitude
test or submit work thirdly how many
interviews will I have to do now this
varies a lot from subject to subject
them from person to person personally I
did four interviews at Oxford I did
three at the college that I apply to and
one at a college that was allocated to
me when I arrived and these all took
place over three days now this is a
relatively common number of interviews
and it's also very common at least for
Oxford to be allocated an additional
college when you arrive this is done to
make sure that
leave a number of applicants interviewed
across the whole University now
some interviewees were asked to stay
back for additional interviews after
their original number we're done and I
wasn't but this is again relatively
common and not something to worry about
it can be done for any number of reasons
and doesn't necessarily say anything
about your application so don't sweat it
if this happens to you a good ballpark
estimate is do you do anything between
two and six interviews though most
people will be at the lower end of that
range for more information about a
particular subjects interview at a
particular College contact that College
directly fourthly how can I best prepare
for my interviews the best way to think
about an interview is a chance to have a
short conversation with leading
academics in a field that you are
passionately interested in and so the
best way to prepare for that
conversation is to make sure you're up
to date on any topics that might come up
and that you're able to clearly
articulate your opinions and ideas if
you get the chance to have a practice
interview then take it it may not be the
most realistic recreation of the
conditions of an interview but any
practice at verbally responding to
questions in your field is great
practice in fact getting into the habit
of talking out loud your thought process
while answering questions is a fantastic
habit to get into
remember that tutors aren't interested
necessarily in you getting to the right
answer if one even exists they're
interesting at how you arrived at your
answer so practice talking through your
thought process and allow them to know
how you think also as far as it's
possible try to relax before going into
your interview
nobody does well when they're stressed
and scared so before you go and try and
get yourself into a calm and happy space
though this is easier said than done
I realize lastly if you'd like to see
how a typical interview goes you can
find several good examples on YouTube
even if the interview isn't in your
subject it gives you a general idea of
how the interview will proceed for a
good example you can check out this
computer science interview from
Cambridge by Jake right